the nave andromeda is now in southampton
and the seven nigerian men in police
custody the decision to launch the
special forces rescue mission
was taken mid-afternoon on sunday a few
hours later
it was all over ship secured crew safe
stairways detained the whole operation
took
under 10 minutes from start to finish i
can't really comment on the operational
details what i can say is that
i think both the police and the armed
forces did a fantastic
job and i thank them very very much for
what they did to
keep our shores safe the nave andromeda
was carrying 22 crew members
and was on route from lagos in nigeria
and due to dock near southampton
at 10 30 on sunday morning but then at
about 9 a.m
the captain made a mayday call saying
that stir ways on board had turned
violent
hampshire police were alerted at 1004
but tracking images showed the vessel
started to steer an erratic
course over the next few hours the sbs
operation to end the standoff
began just after 7pm once darkness had
settled
and as the weather was just starting to
turn bad
four military helicopters thought to
include two merlin mark
ivs a wild cat and a chinook took 40
personnel to the scene
from the sbs's base in pool 16 commandos
fast roped onto the deck
and snipers on board the helicopters
gave cover
a nearby royal navy frigate hms richmond
was put on standby in the english
channel
and royal navy divers were on hand in
case the ship had been mined
the defense secretary ben wallace gave
the operation the green light
and he was kept updated on a secure line
from his home
shortly before 8 pm in the evening news
of the operation
started to leak out on the isle of wight
and then
at 8 16 pm the ministry of defence
confirmed that british armed forces had
retaken the ship
the tanker was finally sailed into
southampton late on sunday night
after a dramatic few hours
the sbs know the waters around the isle
of wight like the backs of their hands
footage on youtube shows commandos
boarding across channel ferry in 2017
on a training exercise it is not
uncommon
to see them exercising around the solent
in the english channel
practicing assaults on cargo ships
tankers and cruise liners
it sounds uh actually a short time but
it's actually quite a long time
um for an op for an operation like that
because you know you've got your
approaches you've got to coordinate your
approaches then you've got to
exit your vehicles be a boat or
helicopter then you've got to
touch down onto the actual vessel or
climb the vessel and then you've got to
make your respective
objectives and on a superstructure like
that you know there's several floors and
so there's quite a lot of area to cover
the seven nigerians are now being
questioned by police and after
an unusually public operation the sbs
have gone back into the shadows
job done alistair bunkel sky news
southampton